what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we got ourselves a trailer for Star Wars
Jedi Survivor and today I'm joined by my great
friend Michael the Tesla from multi-house.io
that's it yeah go check it out I've done
stuff with them I'm gonna continue to do
stuff with them he's like one of the biggest
Star Wars nerds I know I mean look at him oh
God we got a real nerd oh you're in so much
trouble Greg you're a big fan of the first
game it like got me through the pandemic I might
have cried a little bit during the first trailer
so I'm excited for this all right do you think
they should leave a like if you don't like And
subscribe uh I don't know what you're doing
you're missing out on some real sexy Greg
content do you ever feel like at night you
need a little bit more energy I mean that's
why I watch real reason I'm about to do a shout
out today guys I'm gonna literally have G fuel
at my wedding and if you know me I always
offered G fuel to everyone who comes into
my household because I absolutely love it you
know what here I'm just gonna I'm gonna just
take you guys on a quick journey in my kitchen
to show you how much you feel I have just so you
know it's in real look look we're right here
here's us now we're gonna go to the kitchen
look at all this G fuel so much
G fuel everywhere oh my God
I think like with just the amount of hours
that uh we can often spend especially since
we're trying to get a week ahead on the
channel oftentimes you need something that
helps you with keeping your energy up and
focus and to not also crash special code
in the description box you guys can
use all right guys let's watch this
view order is gone I was betrayed by
the one I trusted most who is this yeah
yeah I will not be imprisoned
again oh [__] oh man damn
I hear you've been busy making
yourself the Empire's Most Wanted
oh my God
friend
remind our friend here why
is God supposed to be dead
dual wielding Jesus Christ Arch okay
look at that it was only grown stronger
oh man
this guy where are they part of the
joke oh my God he's got himself in front
oh look at this oh my god
oh [__] I cannot get over this
survives
previous destroys
ah yeah you just saw in the the background they
had the the CIS oh my God I was wanting them to
show them using the the Blaster oh I wanted to see
you I wanted to see you it was like wait a minute
dude that was uh I'm like that was that
was a big freaking trailer right there
yeah there's there's like a lot to unpack
yeah that was uh wow that was a beautiful
ass trailer the dual wielding and there
are parts of this that remind me you
played a force unleashed oh dude that's
exactly uh like I hope Cal's not too Opie
yeah the fleshing out of the environments the way
they utilize everything like it just feels like
such a massive upgrade because this really does
feel like you're a Jedi being brought to life even
though it was mainly gameplay they do tease some
story elements so this is the second time they're
teasing that person the back the tank do you have
any idea who this villain might be or any Theory
so so I have faith in our Lord and savior is Dave
filoni and John Favreau that there is a master
plan going on right now that incorporates this
that incorporates this Rebels that incorporates
Ahsoka Mandalorian book of boba and a lot of it
comes down to this cloning facility was teased
in bad batch and that definitively is like
where like Palpatine's son and like all the
Snokes were made this comes from a Legend's uh
storyline that like I loved as a kid where there
was this like Jedi supremacist like from way back
in the day who is like Jedi or bust but like took
it a little too far based on what we saw I think
that my might be him or at least an inspiration or
some iteration it makes sense like where we
leave Cal off is like you know he wanted to
rebuild the Jedi Order and all the grand Masters
are gone he had to destroy you know the the list
of all the young ones the holocrons leaves us in
this like really interesting spot where if you're
looking for help and there's like rumor of like an
all-powerful Jedi that could take on the emperor
and it turns out when you let him go he's maybe
not the guy I love the the tease of him because
like Trilla third sister was a wonderfully nuanced
antagonist in that game kind of get the impression
here there'll be a similar thing where there'll
be a lot of pathos to this character where it'll
could have a similar effect where you're like all
right he was menacing when we first met him but I
kind of get where he's coming from or they might
just double down and make him like extra evil
or some [__] like that I wonder how long this I
didn't read much about what this game is supposed
to be about so I wonder how long the separation is
yeah it's I think it's been like five years or so
she made some comment there about like here you've
been kicking ass or something and that seemed like
particularly seeing her again number one like her
look was awesome it's nice to see her a little
bit more Regal yeah like at peace with her and
like the force it was particularly neat seeing
the Jedi archives uh which is something like like
they've teased it in some of the Canon literature
but they haven't showed it yet but like the grand
librarian of the Jedi survives Order 66 tries to
preserve a lot of that knowledge and I love the
idea of getting to see her again at least in some
kind of something um I'm not gonna spoil what
happens to her but first person I know to ever
tease the librarian for there it's dude she was
she was my first love you know some people are
into like lay in a bikini me it was well I'm into
this uh new uh scoundrel solo replacement yeah
the team enough together looks cool find yourself
a friend that you know you can jump over like
that I think the last thing uh you you said
Knights of REM but I thought the Knights of
Ren came after yeah so so that's a common kind of
misconception so like a bunch of dumb asses out
there so there's a compliment conception about no
so when Ben solo okay kylo is uh training at the
Jedi Temple the Knights of Ren were like out and
about they were already a thing and um he ended
up grouping up with them and uh the kicking the
leader's ass and killing him and the leader was
like a super badass guy if it kind of reminds
me of this fella based on like the canonical
description of him the other direction that this
maybe could go just like based on on that jet pack
yeah is you know this is when the the siege of
Mandalore around the time that that happens yeah
you know and and so he could very much be be
Death Watch or you know one of the he kind of
has like that Vibe of like the armorer from the
Mandalorian I feel like the Knights of Ren were
one of those things that they just like screwed
the pooch on like totally they looked awesome we
don't know what you know we don't know anything so
you know it would be really cool to be able to to
see them kind of go backwards and and tell the
story that probably would have given some cool
contact especially if that's like an OP villain
that you can't beat um but the only one that did
was kylo hey a Boy Can Dream I like his lightsaber
a lot that's me that's my commentary yeah I mean
it's it's it's cool I mean I always something I
loved about Cal's character is like little Flames
I have the greatest lights he has a little homage
to to his master in there and it's been five years
later like clearly he's not a Padawan anymore
um so it's gonna be exciting to see him kind of
step into his step into his own I mean it looks
like the game is starting off or he's in his own
room this was the the the lightsaber from the Old
Republic um like last time we saw that uh was like
it was it was right when uh Vader and Ahsoka
had their um Rebel rematch uh but you know
the long anticipating reunion um and yeah as
Ezra finds that at the scene of a battlefield
between the ancient Jedi and the ancient Sith
and so like if I'm going to get like a little
conspiracy theory here for a second you have
this Old Republic element that they're clearly
pushing you have this like Legends character
that could very well be inspired by this like
sure I don't know I get a lot of like Knights
of the Old Republic Vibes dude I'm glad you were
here you actually had a lot to say it's not
all going to be in the video guys oh that's
okay but when we do the shows you're gonna
have a lot to say oh it's it's it's going
to be a blast you did great Michael great
great first video it's not easy being here
it's not it's not easy being green I often uh make
people feel very tense and uncomfortable in their
first videos and you overcame the challenge no
I'm just intense and uncomfortable and naturally
so it's a you know well I love it I loved your
working Moneyball and Wolf of Wall Street and
yeah guys well what'd you think of the trailer
your thoughts down below subscribe leave a like
follow Michael and whatever the link is in the
description box and I follow him on the Mt Tesla
MJ Tesla and May the force be with you May the
force be with all of you you sons of [__]